if you had to start all over again from
the beginning and build your wealth up
which industry would you say is the most
lucrative would you get into
um Finance banking crypto content
creation real estate where would you
start such a great question my answer is
a different question my answer is I
don't care about the industry
I want to I want to work with a killer
it's who I want to work with I want to
work with somebody that is absolutely
non-stop obsessed very good at what I
don't give that guy's in real estate if
it's an insurance if it's in crypto if
it's in pharmaceutical sales I don't
care if it's in technology coding don't
care if you're the best and you're the
only one to have access to getting
closer to working with I want to learn
your habits I want to learn your
day-to-day I want to learn your
obsession I want to learn how you
negotiate Beyond closed doors there is
this camera that people are watching
right now with our interview run but
they haven't seen how I negotiate when
I'm doing negotiations on the call or
resume with other people so they don't
know how that works versus when you're
in the room and you're seeing how
uncomfortable it gets at one point and
your three of my guys sitting there and
then you six years later you're
negotiating that way the value of that
is not let me do a course and teach you
how to negotiate if I'm able to work
with somebody in any industry I am very
much open to any industry if I'm 21
years old coming out I'm going to work
with anybody as long as that person is a
killer
I want to talk about the negotiation and
how uncomfortable that can be because I
know how uncomfortable that can be and I
so I actually don't like to do it I have
men that do that because it's just it's
just better for me but talk to you about
why that's uncomfortable how do you deal
with that level of Confrontation and how
do you also walk away from a deal
because you're just not happy with
what's on the table it's so much fun I
mean I find it so uncomfortable it would
be like to me a good debate a good the
other day we had a guy on the podcast
Antonio Brown who uh uh uh the most
uncomfortable podcasts we've ever done
who just called words everything you an
idiot you don't know what you're talking
about you acting like a girl like this
and at one point at the podcast sitting
there saying huh okay what are we gonna
do here right now I really don't need to
be here this guy is very difficult but
let's see if we can break through this
year so that additional let me take a
different angle on the way I'm going to
communicate with them and see where we
can go and in the conversation one two I
heard you like to swim yeah I like to
swim I said
how early do you swim in the morning
because I know how old were you when you
first started swim I was a kid why do
you like swimming so because when you're
underwater you don't hear anything
interesting I love that okay so that's
like a concept of bike motorcycle when
you're out there motorcycle you don't
hear anything it's like you're in a
certain mode right I said so tell me
about this and then we went into Brady
and then he made a comment about Brady
and what he does so Brady had your back
why'd you do this and then that video
was went viral all over the media
they're writing about it but that is a
form of negotiation in an interview
where it gets uncomfortable and if you
take the right turn it's about to be a
very interesting interview versus oh my
God I made them upset it's uncomfortable
let me back down so in negotiation
you're going to hear that you're going
to hit that wall as well we're at one
point one party or both parties are
going to be uncomfortable and whoever
cannot
whoever cannot handle it in that moment
uh and by the way here's the other part
I used to be the one where negotiating
was about 100 me winning and the other
person losing and then I noticed as a 20
year old people weren't coming back to
want to keep doing business with me so
that's not the right way either you have
to do it in a way where you're making
money they're making money someone's
always going to get a little bit of a
better better deal right you know and
it's always like MCI I think it was MCI
and atnt or somebody like them when
somebody bought atnt and the company
that bought a TNT they they were bigger
so at T is like well we're not okay with
you buying us why not it says because of
our name he says of course if we buy you
we're going to use your name not ours
so to ATT that's a win because they
wanted to keep the name a TNT to the
other companies like we don't care what
the name is we're big we want to buy you
we'll let the company so imagine like
actually let's process this as a bigger
company imagine let's pick a name
Ford motor company buys give me a small
car company whatever small car company
and Ford is willing to change the
company's name to the other car company
even though that's kind of what happens
so in negotiation ATT still felt like
day one because a legacy the name so but
it's a game it's a beautiful game and if
you do it right more people want to
negotiate with you I was 31 years old
sitting there negotiating with a guy
named Harry okay now I'm going to tell
you the full name but he's probably
gonna fears about this so we were
sitting there he says Pat I'm afraid to
do business with you I said tell me why
he's a Wharton business school guy I
love this guy spend time with him and
his wife and he wanted to invest and I
said uh listen this is the percentage
that I'm willing to do at this
investment he says you know it's it's
midnight we're at my office we've been
talking for five hours he says you know
I'm afraid to negotiate with you he says
what he says because I'm afraid you're
going to get the better deal and not me
I said let's just say that's the truth
but let me kind of give you something
else for you to be thinking about I said
let's say that does happen wouldn't you
want your running mate to be a
ridiculous negotiator if you and I are
Partners together he says I would I said
if you come in with this with this
investment I'm officially going to
negotiate the deals for the rest of your
life why don't we do this together you
know what he does he doesn't do the deal
oh he doesn't doesn't do the deal why
not you know how much it costs them you
know what his investment would have made
him 40 times this investment would have
made him wow 40 times he knows it why
wasn't he convinced because he still
thought I was getting the better deal
right he had he had a hard time with him
by the way you know how much it cost me
for not doing that deal
he helped me maybe he made more money
I don't know 25 million 40 million bucks
just by him saying no so I appreciate
you thank you so much man for not
wanting to take that offer that's
amazing what a sweetheart of a guy no
absolutely it's a major shout out to
Harry great guy
very thankful for Harry it's actually a
really good guy good family guy but yeah
cost himself 40 million but no good in
business
but he's afraid he's afraid okay go to
take some rest you do sometimes by the
way you know I don't blame him because
at that time I was not yet proven I was
only proven to be a great sales leader
right and a great sales person I'd never
run a company I'd never exited a company
so his writ his risk was valid that he
had that concern but I also knew I was
going places it makes a lot of sense um
foreign
[Music]